are just some breaking news coming into
us now and that is that Cumbria police
confirming that the body of a teenager
has been found in a river in Carlisle
this is a teenage boy that's been found
in the river Eden in Carlisle and the
body was found in the river near to the
Rosehill area shortly after 1 30 p.m so
this afternoon the discovery of the body
police say follows an extensive what
they describe as multi-agency search
operation in response to an incident
where a group of teenage boys had got
into difficulty in the river Eden now
one of the group which is a 15 year old
from Carlisle was missing following that
incident this is the report that the
police is putting out the police also
stressing that no formal identification
has yet been confirmed however they go
on to say that the family of the 15 year
old boy have been informed and they are
being supported by Specialists officers
the file they say will be prepared for
the coroner we also do have a statement
coming in from Chief superintendent Lisa
Hogan who's A from Cumbria constabulary
and she says here this is a tragic
incident and our thoughts are with the
family of the 15 year old boy at this
difficult time an extensive search
operation has taken place since the
incident was reported yesterday evening
the search activity was assisted by
Emergency Services search and rescue
teams and Specialists professionals from
Cumbria and the from outside of the
county that's the end of that statement
there but police also confirming that
they were contacted at about 20 to 7
yesterday evening of course the 26th of
May but this morning the news coming in
from police that a teenage boy believed
to be a 15 year old boy his body has
been discovered this afternoon in the
river Eden in Carlisle his family we're
being told I've been informed